Wow I would like to thank the Academy
Board of Governors for this honorable
recognition which moves me deeply
as a Mexican as an artist and most
importantly as a human being I thank you
from the depth of my heart for taking
the time to experience Carmy arena and
honor it with this special award and
there is no better price in life than
the one that you win without competing
and with no award seasons and to share
the space with great great masters mr.
Madame a nice Bharatha or one Rosamond
Charlie's Burnett and Donald Sutherland
is a dream this project was born as a
creative experiment with no commercial
or profit intention and so many people
just trusted in it and gave so much even
when we didn't know how to do it or how
it will end and I would like to thank
them first I would like to thank first
my dear friend and collaborator Eamon
Welch evil whisky
this project will not be what it is
without his genius to marry parent
producer friend and guardian engine of
this project marry you and legendary
made this project possible thank you
very much
to Miuccia Prada who was the first
conspirators of this idea five years ago
and her team at fundación a Prada to
Laurene Powell Jobs and Emerson
collected for their support and
commitment to the cause of immigrants to
producer Cathy Calhoun and her passion
to team Alexander and a team of ILM to
eat and Stern's for his abortion and
Philip Messina for his beautiful design
my brother Martin Hernandez Karsten
Nicolai Randy thorn Steve Golan Neil
color house and the real VR pioneer nani
de la pena - our non milchin for make
the installation at LACMA possible and
to Michael govern and his team at LACMA
for taking us in even when this was only
an idea - tre Freeman Michael Mann and
John Bailey for their support and
believed in this project to be Guillermo
del Toro Alfonso Cuaron for their
friendship and always always wise and
dangerous advice - stubble Flores
etiquette yet happier chap Eduardo
Vasquez Corky Volpe ricardo rafael la
ciudad de mexico Nam and atlatl local
museum - Alejandro Ramirez or helping
make this installation in Mexico
possible - may your sound for donating
their equipment and their services to
Merrill area my wife my son and my
daughter le7 Merrill area who I love and
contain compared to la conciencia
immigrants and finally but not any less
important to Federico Bustamante
director of casa livery and to each and
every one of the immigrants who trust us
and participate in this project sharing
their stories to the world and they made
this project something theirs and really
true I would like now to say and to
share
some reflection and I promise I will do
my best to improve my very bad English
but I want to say that our only only
ideologies have [ __ ] up the world not
the people but the ideas we have about
those people and these ideas and the
ideas that they have about us those
ideas are attached to words words that
only serve to reiterate and reaffirm
those ideas our ideas but the idea of a
thing place or person is not the twelth
in place or person it is just an
abstraction a word is just an
interpretation that inevitably picking
holes and reduce the complex and true
reality of that thing place or person
ideologies as its names indicates only
feet from ideas and words are the
bullets that we should towards reality
because the biggest enemy ideologies
have is reality and the interpretation
of reality only through ideas and words
inevitably distances mislead blind us
and prevent us from actually seeing
reality when the world let's put an
example rapist or illegal alien is fired
the reality of a certain human life or a
community the whole community is reduced
to an idea and whoever's believes or
possess and fires that idea ends up
impoverishing misleading and degrading
their perception of reality and the one
of everyone around them but no matter
how many tweets to the right or to the
lair
and all our blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
real true reality will remain on altar
if 10 years ago while preparing my film
Babel I had the privilege getting a
glimpse into the reality of hundreds of
Mexican and Central American immigrants
most of them woman children and young
people whose lives had been devastated
by extreme poverty domestic violence
hunger war rape and death threats from
violent cartels and gangs their
situation was so desperate that they
were willing to become one more among
the six thousand immigrants who have
died during the last ten years in the
desert while seeking for life refuge
willing to risk their lives and die with
their children rather than returning to
their home countries our countries who
have failed betray and abandon them
every phrase every story each one of the
realities was deeply touching and movie
I don't know how many of the people who
will soon decide the future of the
800,000 daca recipients have have the
privilege of meeting one of them in
person look that look them in the eyes
or listen to their stories but I am sure
that if they do and see the real reality
firsthand they will understand them and
if they understand them they will love
them because as master tick not hand
said understanding Islam loves other
name if you don't understand you can't
love carnea Reina is a humble first
attempt at exploring the human condition
and expressing and sharing a reality
through the birth of a new art yes we
are standing in the face of a new art
form whose language and visual grammar
we are attempt
we are still attempting to understand
and which the new generations will
explore and discover taking it to on
in places our intention from the
beginning was to subordinate the
technology to the human emotions to
explore one of the oldest themes and
conflicts in human history with the
newest technology possible a technology
that depending on how it is used will
separate us altering reducing and
deforming our perception of reality with
only bulgar profit-driven
interest or will unite us by giving us
artistic experiences or even if only
beautifully a slice of our complex
reality so that we can understand each
other and therefore love each other more
personally I am NOT interested in
technology to reinvent or escape reality
I am interested in technology as a tool
to embrace reality unlike in the immense
ocean submerge myself and discover
transform appreciates beauty and great
mystery today right here millions of
people seeking refuge are virtually
present all thought physical invisible I
dedicate and receive this beautiful
recognition on behalf of all the
immigrants from Mexico Central America
Asia Africa and all corners of the world
whose reality has been ignored and held
hostage by ideologies and definitions
denying them the possibility of being
understood and loved thank you very much
[Applause]